meagan markle's big disney debut is
almost here I never thought my life
would be that awesome Disney Plus gave
us our first look at elephant on
Thursday an upcoming feature in
collaboration with Disney nature
narrated by Megan Markel herself
elephant narrated by Megan the Duchess
of Sussex sadly we don't hear Megan's
voice in the trailer but the movie is
set to hit the streaming service on
April 3rd as for when the 38 year old
Duchess hit the recording booth et has
learned that Megan did the voice work
for elephant last fall according to our
source she became aware of the project
through mutual friends of the filmmakers
who then asked if she'd be interested in
lending her voice for the narration we
first learned Megan might be teaming up
with Disney when this happened that was
Harry pitching his wife to then Disney
CEO Bob Iger at the London premiere of
The Lion King Iger later opened up about
his conversation with a couple while
chatting with et at the Oscars what did
Megan Markel say to you and we had a
lovely conversation first time I met her
I've known him a while and he was a
Toombs talk to me about the fact that
she was potentially going to track a
film well we now know that Eiger was
referring to elephant which will
premiere alongside Natalie Portman's
narration of dolphin reef in recognition
of Earth Month
according to reports Megan agreed to do
the project in exchange for a donation
to Botswana charity Elephants Without
Borders so Disney nature and the Disney
Conservation Fund are doing just that
our source says this is currently
Megan's only voiceover deal with Disney
but she and Harry are scheduled to
officially exit the royal family on
March 31st as planned which means they
will have to start earning their own
income
we need Megan and Harry are making the
rules themselves we all take a leap of
faith so thank you for giving me the
courage to take this
step
[Music]